>> NI ROBERTSON, A GUESSING
GAME AT THIS POINT.
THAT REPORT FROM NIC ROBERTSON.
JOINING ME, FORMER DEFENSE
SECRETARY LEON PANETTA AND SERVE
UNDER PRESIDENT CLINTON WHITE
HOUSE CHIEF OF STAFF.
GREAT SEE YOU.
AS ALWAYS.
THIS IDEA RUSSIA ALREADY HAS 70%
OF MILITARY CAPABILITIES IN
PLACE FOR A FULL-SCALE INVASION
OF UKRAINE AND INTELLIGENCE
ESTIMATES COMING IN SAYING THAT
THE CAPITAL CITY OF UKRAINE
WOULD FALL WITHIN 48 HOURS.
THAT'S ALARMING STUFF, YET SAME
TIME I CAN'T MAKE HEADS OR TAILS
WHY UKRAINE ISN'T MORE IN A
STATE OF PANIC ABOUT THIS?
OR ALARMED ABOUT THIS?
HOW ALARMED ARE YOU?
>> WELL, I THINK IT'S A
DANGEROUS MOMENT, AND I THINK
WHETHER YOU'RE UKRAINIAN OR
AMERICAN OR FOR THAT MATTER A
CITIZEN ANYWHERE IN THE WORLD,
THIS IS A DANGEROUS MOMENT IN
THE 21st CENTURY.
WHY?
BECAUSE RUSSIA CONTINUES TO ADD
FUEL TO THE FIRE, AND THE MORE
THEY CONTINUE TO BUILD UP THEIR
MILITARY FORCES, THE MORE LIKELY
THAT A SPARK WILL SET OFF THAT
FIRE AND CREATE A WAR.
THAT NOBODY WANTS.
BUT THAT'S WHAT MAKES THIS A
DANGEROUS MOMENT, AND I THINK IS
IS
-- ZELENSKY UNDERSTANDS THE
DANGER AND TRYING TO KEEP HIS
PEOPLE UP SO A DIPLOMATIC
SOLUTION CAN BE ARRIVED AT BUT
EVERYTHING POINTS TO THE REAL
POSSIBILITY OF WAR.
>> AS YOU KNOW, U.S. OFFICIALS
ALLEGED THIS WEEK RUSSIA COULD
BE PLAYING A RELEASE OF SOME
SORT OF FAKE ATTACK, A VIDEO
FAKE ATTACK AGAINST THEM AS A
PRETEXT FOR INVASION.
MEANTIME, WE JUST SAW IMAGES OF
PUTIN AND CHINA'S PRESIDENT XI
JINPING LOOKING VERY COZY AT THE
OLYMPICS.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF ALL OF THESE
DEVELOPMENTS, AND ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS I HAVE ABOUT ALL OF
THIS IS, YOU KNOW FROM YOUR
STANDPOINT AS A FORMER DEFENSE
SECRETARY.
THE UNITED STATES PUTTING TROOPS
INTO EASTERN EUROPE.
INTO THAT THEATER.
IN THE MIDDLE OF ALL OF THIS.
IS THAT A GOOD IDEA?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, THERE ARE TWO
POSITIONS GOING ON HERE.
ONE IS THE RUSSIAN POSITION,
WHICH IS MILITARY ACTION.
MILITARY THREAT TO INVADE A
SOVEREIGN COUNTRY.
AND THE UNITED STATES AND OUR
ALLIES HAVE TAKEN ANOTHER
POSITION, WHICH IS TO TRY TO
STRESS DETERRENCE AND THE FACT
RUSSIA WILL PAY A VERY HEAVY
PRICE IF THEY DECIDE ON MILITARY
ACTION, AND DIPLOMACY.
IN THE HOPE THAT THEY'LL BE
WILLING TO SIT DOWN AND
NEGOTIATE A PEACEFUL SOLUTION.
RUSSIA IS GOING TO TRY TO GET
THE SUPPORT OF ANOTHER OUGHT
CRAT IN CHINA.
PRESIDENT XI IS PUTTING HIS OWN
COUNTRY IN A SITUATION HERE.
IF THEY GO TO WAR, MAKE NO
MISTAKE, XI WILL BEAR PART OF
THE RESPONSIBILITY FOR WHAT'S
HAPPENED.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT THE JANUARY
6th INVESTIGATION NOW, AS WE
MENTIONED EARLIER, YOU WERE ONCE
A WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF STAFF.
MANY LIFETIMES AGO.
MANY YEARS AGO IN YOUR CAREER.
YOUR REACTION TO REPORTING FROM
THE "WASHINGTON POST" THAT TRUMP
WAS CONSTANTLY RIPPING UP
IMPORTANT DOCUMENTS WHILE IN THE
WHITE HOUSE, AND THAT HIS
STAFFERS WOULD DECIDE AMONGST
THEMSELVES WHICH SHOULD BE TAPED
BACK TOGETHER AGAIN.
YOU KNOW, WHICH ONES WOULD BE
TOSSED INTO BURN BAGS.
I GUESS INCINERATED AT THE
PENTAGON.
THIS IS -- THIS IS CRAZY STUFF.
>> YOU KNOW, WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
PUTIN, NOT RECOGNIZING ANY
INTERNATIONAL RULES.
NOT FOLLOWING ANY OF THE
STANDARDS THAT WE WOULD BELIEVE
WOULD BE THE CASE IN THE
CIVILIZED WORLD AND BASICALLY
THREATENING TWO INVADE A
SOVEREIGN COUNTRY, CLAIMS THAT
IT'S PART OF RUSSIA.
CRAZY STUFF.
AND YET WE'RE HEARING THE SAME
THING HERE IN THE UNITED STATES
FROM WHAT TRUMP DID.
TRUMP BASICALLY WAS IGNORING THE
RULE OF LAW, IGNORING THE
CONSTITUTION, IGNORING ALL OF
THE REQUIREMENTS OF BEING A
PRESIDENT.
PRESIDENTS ARE NOT SUPPOSED TO
DESTROY DOCUMENTS IN THE WHITE
HOUSE.
THEY'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO
OBVIOUSLY TELL A VICE PRESIDENT
THAT HE CAN BASICALLY CALL AN
ELECTION IN VIOLATION OF OUR
CONSTITUTION.
AND YET THAT, IN MANY WAYS, IS
WHAT THIS COUNTRY IS DEALING
WITH AS WELL.
>> RIGHT.
WE HAVE OUR OWN ISSUES DOWN IN
MAR-A-LAGO.
TOTE ON "FACE THE NATION"
SENATOR MARCO RUBIO WAS ASKED IF
HE AGREED WITH MIKE PENCE, WHEN
HE SAID TRUMP WAS WRONG FRIDAY
ABOUT FORMER VICE PRESIDENT
HAVING THE POWER TO OVERTURN THE
ELECTION AND HERE WAS RUBIO'S
RESPONSE.
>> DO YOU AGREE WITH MIKE PENCE?
>> WELL, PRESIDENT BIDEN RUNS
FOR RE-ELECTION I BELIEVE HE
WOULD DEFEAT JOE BIDEN AND I
DON'T WANT KAMALA HARRIS TO HAVE
THE POWER AS VICE PRESIDENT TO
OVERTURN THAT ELECTION AND
THAT'S THE SAME THING THAT I
CONCLUDED BACK IN JANUARY OF
2021.
>> SO DONALD TRUMP WAS WRONG?
>> WELL, ICE SAID, I JUST DON'T
THINK THE VICE PRESIDENT HAS
THAT POWER.
>> RIGHT.
>> THE VICE PRESIDENT HAS THAT
POWER DONALD TRUMP WILL DEFEAT
JOE BIDEN IN FOUR YEARS AND
KAMALA HARRIS CAN DECIDE NOT TO
OVERTURN THE ELECTION.
I DON'T WANT TO WIND UP THERE.
>> HOW IS THAT SUCH A HARD
QUESTION TO ANSWER, DO YOU
THINK?
>> I -- I THINK REPUBLICANS HAVE
TWISTED THEMSELVES INTO A
POSITION THAT MAKES IT VERY
DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO BASICALLY
SPEAK THE TRUTH, AND, YOU KNOW,
I THINK SENATOR RUBIO SHOULD
HAVE JUST SAID THAT THE VICE
PRESIDENT WAS CORRECT, THAT NO
VICE PRESIDENT CAN DECLARE WHO
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES IS.
THAT IS THE TRUTH.
AND I THINK REPUBLICANS, IF THEY
FRANKLY WOULD TAKE A STAND FOR
THE TRUTH OF WHAT OUR
CONSTITUTION SAYS, THAT THEY
WOULD BE IN MUCH BETTER SHAPE
POLITICALLY THAN TRYING SOMEHOW
TO USE CONTORTED LOGIC IN ORDER
TO DEFEND TRUMP.
>> YEAH.
AND PAINFUL TO WATCH.
ALL RIGH